my name is arya and i will be dedicating
the next three months of my life towards
training in mixed martial arts before
competing in an officially sanctioned
fight against a trained and experienced
opponent
i'm worried about him i don't know if
he's a fighter he's too nice
i get the impression that there's an
underdog within you that is trying to
prove something through this experience
a common thing that is brought up is
always people saying oh you you can't do
this you're too nice to be able to do
this and you want to be fearless
yeah
and although four months in muay thai it
looks like arya's got a bit of a stance
on him
well he's certainly gained you know he's
standing right in front of casey and
throwing punches so
he's not afraid to get in there and mix
it up
he's in trouble here though
he's caught in the front headlock here
he's in danger of getting guillotined if
casing can connect his hands
oh he went all the way out choked him
all the way out
[Music]
and arya interval goes to sleep in his
debut fight here versus case and match
when i stepped in that cage two years
ago i didn't expect to want to do it
again
[Music]
i didn't expect the countless messages
of support i continue to receive from so
many of you
and i also didn't expect that it would
take me this long to fight again
this time i want to bring you on the
journey with me
so follow me as i train and explore what
it really means to be a fighter
last time i was fighting for myself
this time
i'm fighting for all of you
and this time
victory
is the only option
[Music]
last time we didn't get the w so we're
going to be pushing arya very hard this
camp and try and get that win jiu jitsu
is definitely not an easy thing i went
100 all the time at arya so we can turn
him into a freaking killer and have him
snap him next
[Music]
arya should be under no illusions about
the fact that this fight will most
definitely be more difficult than his
first a first loss it could be inspiring
to train harder or it could be
devastating to your confidence and just
shoot you straight down this fight we'll
see whether arya will fold or if he'll
rise above
[Music]
you